la situation actuelle est intenable une
croissance exponentielle dans un monde
fini ne peut pas durer éternellement
on
alors que la science depuis des
décennies nous explique la catastrophe
qui est en cours il est maintenant
maintenant pas dans deux ans comme le
gui l'onu pendant dix ans comme le
disent les plus sages maintenant
nécessaire de prendre les mesures
radicales crois que c'est indispensable
que la réception du sérieux change de
camp on ne peut pas continuer à donner
l'image d'écologistes qui sont des doux
dingues qui sont des rêveurs qui sont
des idéologues ou des idéalistes tandis
que les économistes néolibéraux seraient
les hommes sérieux en costume cravate
soyons clairs être devant le gouffre et
accélérer ce n'est pas sérieux et c'est
ce que nous recommande pas tout ça mais
un certain nombre d'économistes c'est en
tout cas le dogme dominant à l'heure
actuelle je crois qu'il faut quand même
rappeler que pour nous autres êtres
vivants membres de la grande tribu des
divans la seule attitude sérieuse c'est
précisément de tenter de continuer à
sauvegarder la vie aujourd'hui
pratiquement plus personne ne doute de
la réalité et de la dramatiser
pourra-t-on dire du changement
climatique
plus personne ne doute de l'extinction
des espèces il n'ya presque plus de
négationniste ils sont ridicules ils
sont discrédités
donc nous savons qu'un génocide contre
l'avis est en cours et pourtant nous
faisons rien c'est comme ça pourra-t-on
dire donc la seule manière de nous
sauver aujourd'hui c'est que le
dirigeant c'est leur rôle
c'est pour ça qu'on ne leur déléguons
notre pouvoir c'est pour ça que nous
l'aurait que nous élisons il faut donc
qu'ils assument leurs fonctions et qu'il
nous sauve ils sont très exactement là
pour ça s'ils ne le font pas ils ne
servent à rien on ne peut plus accorder
notre confiance à un pouvoir politique
qui ne ferait pas de l'écologie sa
priorité parce qu'un tel pouvoir n'irait
la vie en elle-même ne peut pas être
gouverné par des gens qui nient la vie
c'est pas possible personne ne souhaite
ça donc nous avons voulu rappeler dans
cette tribune que toute politique qui
n'était pas prioritairement écologique
est aujourd'hui caduc
parce qu'elle était tout simplement un
crime contre l'avenir je pense qu'il
faut des mesures coercitives
on ne peut pas continuer à faire
semblant de laisser entendre que tout
est compatible avec tout une croissance
débridée n'est pas possible sans avoir
des conséquences dramatiques sur la vie
sur terre
la vie humaine et la vie animale
autrement dit vraisemblablement il faut
effectivement s'opposer à un peu
autre liberté à un peu notre confort
mais c'est finalement pour avoir la
possibilité de continuer à jouir d'une
planète habitable
quand on interdit un ivrogne de prendre
le volant bien sûr il le ressent comme
une perte de liberté
enfin ça permet quand même de sauver la
vie des enfants qui vont traverser la
route et personne ne niera que ce qu'une
bonne chose c'est un peu pareil
aujourd'hui nous avons des comportements
des attitudes qui sont les talent qui
sont en train de tuer la planète
eh bien peut-être faut-il accepter de
perdre un tout petit peu la liberté de
ce confort de façon à sauvegarder ce qui
n'est quand même pas tout à fait un
bétail et qu'on appelle le monde
[Musique]